men are apparently too manly
you're hit you're bleeding man I ain't
got time to breathe
okay the Washington Post blaming
Republicans for a quote Cowboy mentality
where men think they can do things by
themselves the paper suggests it could
be a factor in the epidemic of male
loneliness in America quote they say a
battle over the face of an American of
American masculinity is underway popular
music action movies and leaders like
former president Donald Trump and
Senator Josh Hawley what push for a more
aggressive model what in the heck is
going on I have friends raising boys and
they just want them to be kind
responsible courageous chivalrous people
gross and thoughtful yes okay what about
what about you go boy you tell me what
you think no I mean I what I love is
that like the idea of toxic masculinity
was created by the media and now they're
going hmm why are men feeling like
they're under attack for like 40 50
years now you've been calling a scum
yeah and it turns out the cure for toxic
masculinity is toxic femininity you know
look at the the hierarchy in the Pyramid
of of sexes at the very bottom you have
men then you have women then you have
minority men minority women and then you
have men becoming women that's the Cure
some lipstick in a dress bottom line
there are two set two Sexes and they
need each other right if if men leave
the system you get Anarchy if women
leave the system you get you get
violence and you get hungry you stole my
joke
what was it actually
I mean get hungry you
that's good we all need more men to
speak up on things like
transgender men whatever I kind of want
to go whatever man competing in women's
sports that's the problem that's we need
more men to speak up about against that
judge I think they should but I I got to
tell you this whole thing made no sense
to me first of all I think the guy's a
generation late okay I don't live in the
world that he's talking about but men
are lonely because they're not like
Cowboys you know loneliness is not new
and it's not limited to men who are not
as Cowboy masculine as Cowboys are and
there's more opportunity now for people
to connect than there ever has been at
any other time in the world so I I don't
know what this guy's talking about is
he's trying to create something new he's
trying to explain the reason for
loneliness
um and it's just it makes no sense he's
just Employments to let their emotions
slow freely that's a generation ago well
to this day Peter will not buy anything
from Gillette
the story in the Washington Post is
hairless yes okay okay is that it's
woman splaining it's a woman writer
interviewing a woman psychologist and I
don't even remember if the psychologist
is the fake one or the real one but it's
a woman named Tara something
interviewing Dr way who identifies as a
she in her biography anyway it's all
woman splaining and if and and and then
and then you're doing the topic so it's
like triple woman explaining
a lot of women explaining yes that's
woman to explain it before we go we
started it all yeah it should be our
conversation well we had help yeah oh my
gosh the Virgin Mary last word to you
woman I I had the Gillette ad was the
example that I wanted to raise but the
epidemic of male loneliness is video
games and porn and too much time in your
mother's basement
get out and get it no I'm trying to
figure out
Greg's like I prefer to be alone yes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else